Gary states allowing online gambling is
this inevitable is it the next big thing
in the gaming business yes
yeah I mean that's it's a-you know this
is great I mean revenue for states saves
us some tax dollars it's happening
anyway it's time for us to be on the
offense on this issue I mean the
percentage New Jersey's taking is
fifteen percent instead of the eight I
mean this is great but an awful lot of
the old line casino operation clean I
believe Sheldon Adelson are taking the
position that oh by the way the record
companies took a couple of decades ago
famous this is a bad idea he's
protecting his game I get that I respect
that too but this technology movement is
inevitable it's time for him and
everybody else is getting hurt by it
jumping on the offense alright embrace
the future don't run away from it soon
next to you we're going to talk about
CEO turnover at a five-year high 43 sp
companies working under new CEOs this
quarter are they jumping ship are
getting shoved out sure Gary yeah shove
is it the activist is it a tougher board
is it activist shareholders maybe it's
all of the above I really honestly so I
think it's the world is changing and
we've got an enormous amount of people
in place right now that grew up with
traditional b-school training lots of
thousand guys with that training who are
not adjusting to the insane speed of
change in marketplaces and the boards
are starting to realize that they don't
want to end up looking like blockbuster
you know and also a lot of boards have
been accused of being too soft not being
activist enough and being too chummy
with the CEO with all due respect to the
boards they look a lot like their CEOs
and that's the problem